seul coup qui vit des bombardements
incessants qui évidemment sont des
crimes de guerre une démocratie ne peut
pas affamer
assoifer bombarder des populations
civiles dans un territoire bloqué donc
le message de la France il est clair
maintenant il faut que l'Union
européenne pèse beaucoup plus pour
éviter la catastrophe elle passe pas
assez pour vous non c'est alors oursola
van derlen a été pathétique en tant que
présidente de la Commission européenne
elle a été complètement à côté de la
plaque euh jeens parce que si vous
voulez euh euh la façon dont elle a
considéré ce qui était d'ailleurs un peu
les premiers mots de la France après les
attentats terroristes du Hamas qui était
de dire au fond on est au côté euh du
peuple palestinien très bien nous sommes
au côté du peuple palestinien mais en
justifiant toute mesure de représaille
du gouvernement israélien qui était
évidemment la limite à ne pas franchir
Madame Van Dery qui pendant son mandat a
donné un visage à la Commission
européenne sur l'Ukraine a plutôt fait
un sans faute là pour le coup à mon avis
par y compris par depuis quelques mois
son atlantisme euh un peu un peu B front
polique c'est par calcul politique ce ce
selon vous on dit par exemple qu'elle a
voulu donner des des gages à à la droite
écoutez oui elle donne des gages à la
droite vous
savez il va y avoir les élections
européennes son mandat futur dépend des
élections européennes est la présidente
de la commission issue de la droite
européenne alors elle a plutôt parfois
joué plutôt intelligemment sur sur le
Green Deal mais là elle est en train de
se réaligner avec la droite européenne
avec la droite allemande qui est
aujourd'hui une droite qui est plus
attirée par l'extrême droite que par la
prise de responsabilité en
responsabilité en lucidité donc sur
cette situationiliser l'Union européenne
pour vous en tout cas elle a participé à
ce que ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
sud global considère que l'Occident
aujourd'hui est en permanence dans le de
de mesure que au fond évidemment encore
une fois comment ne pas être au côté du
peuple israélien après des attentats
d'une barbarerie sans nom mais il nous
faut y compris parce que israël est une
démocratie moi je
[Musique]
dénonce